a los 18 años su mayor cambio no está
particularmente preocupada por su futuro
profesional llevo un año en formación y
ya tiene un trabajo asignado
y ahora voy a comprobar cómo será la
iluminación cuando instale cinco
lámparas
ella forma parte de la generación que
creció con angela merkel en el poder un
periodo de 16 años marcado por grandes
crisis pero también por su mano firme
para dirigir al país
fernando nacimos después del 11 de
septiembre pero vino la crisis
financiera y otros eventos que nos
asustaron cuando éramos pequeños angela
merkel se convirtió en una referencia
para mí y mi generación ella es la
encarnación de alemania
bones desde 2005 el desempleo juvenil ha
caído desde el 15 al 6% estos aprendices
sienten cariño por merkel en primer
lugar está la continuidad también su
naturaleza tranquila realmente no
tenemos nada de qué quejarnos pero si la
canciller deja atrás un país
económicamente fuerte
[Aplausos]
y muchos jóvenes están preocupados por
lo que sigue para el planeta
la generación de los viernes por el
futuro por ejemplo un poco más grieta
que angela para ellos el legado de la
canciller es uno de oportunidades
perdidas
si tan solo hubiéramos continuado el
desarrollo de energía renovable lo
habríamos hecho mejor para la economía y
el empleo en ese frente del gobierno de
merkel se ha equivocado por completo en
los últimos 16 años tenemos que actuar
ahora para salvar nuestro futuro
realmente es hora de pasar a otra cosa
unos 3 millones de electores primerizos
tienen la oportunidad de votar el 26 de
septiembre una generación que duda sobre
la dirección a seguir una encuesta
reveló que la mitad de ellos están
indecisos